The next thing I want to talk about
is what happens in the system on
Page Evictions.
Remember that on Page Eviction, when a
Node decides that it wants to throw out
a page, it sends it in the algorithm
that I described to the Node.
Which is candidly ignored for
hosting that page, and
it might use the weight
information to make the decision.
Of which node to send that page that
it is discarding from it's own node.
When a page fault happens, the key thing
is to make sure that we service
the page fault so that we get the page.
And restart the execution that
has been stalled on this node.
That's the important thing to do.
The less important thing, but
something that needs to happen
in the universe of things
that is being managed by GMS,
is to also send the victim page
from this node to the target node.
That's part of the algorithm for
eviction on page four.
However, we don't want to do
it on every page fault, but
we want to do it in
an aggregated manner.
And for that reason every
node has a paging daemon.
And this is typical of virtual memory
systems that when a page fault happens.
That's not the time the virtual memory
manager is running around trying to
find the page free.
It always has a stash of free
page frames to allocate.
To service this particular page fault.
As I mentioned earlier, the paging
daemon in the virtual memory manager
is integrated with the GMS system.
And what the paging
daemon is going to do is,
when the free list falls below
a threshold, then the paging
daemon is going to do put page of
the oldest pages on this node.
And remember that in
the integration of GMS with
the virtual memory
manager in the put page,
I said that the Paging Daemon is
also modified to work with the GMS.
This is where the modification comes in.
Normally what the Paging Daemon
would've done is when the free list
goes below threshold,
it would take a bunch of pages,
LRU candidate pages, and
put it all onto the disc.
But with the integration with GMS, what
the paging demon is going to do is, for
the same condition when the freelist
falls below threshold, it's going to
basically do putpage of the oldest
pages that it has on this node.
And when we do the put page, we're
going to choose the candidate node.
Where we going to do the putpage based
on the weight information that we got
as part of the geriatric management
that we talked about in the beginning.
And so we do a putpage of UID.
Into this PFD of this node so
that this guy will be the one that
will be backing this particular UID.
And once I do this,
I also have to update the GCD
to indicate that the new PFD for
this particular UID is C.
So this update message is being
sent to the owner of this UID.
That is this node, and
the owner the guy that has the portion
of the UID space that is
managed by this node.
So the GCD data structure
contains the mapping of the UID
to the node that contains the PFD for
that particular UID.
And so I send this update message saying
please update the GCD to indicate that
this particular UID is now backed
by PFD that sites on note C.
So that's the information
I'm sending to this guy.
And this is not being done
on every page eviction, but
it is done by the paging demon in
a aggregated, coordinated manner.
When the free list falls
below a threshold.
So we've covered a lot of ground from
just sort of the principal
behind the thought experiment.
That is, using network memory as
a paging device, rather than disc.
Because the networks have gotten faster.
And we came up with an algorithm for
age management globally in the entire
cluster, and how to have that
age management done in a manner
that doesn't burden any one node.
But it picks the node that is lightest
in terms of load at any point of time.
And we also saw given the solution for
cluster white memory management for
paging, how to go about implementing it.
And all of the heavy lifting that
needs to be done in order to take
an idea and put it into practice.